in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Berto
and Ashley are with us hey guys how are
you hi welcome welcome so you're here to
do your debt-free screen I love it where
do you live
Kissimmee Florida oh oh the Orlando area
very fun so what are your t-shirts say I
can't read them from here debt free
scream with Dave Ramsey oh there we go
that'll work very cool
good so how much debt have you guys paid
off $48,000
that took two years in two years making
what kind of money we started off when
we first started that FPU on at the end
of that year we made 30 and then the
next year we made 42 Wow very cool what
do you do for a living well I'm a
teacher I just started teaching in
January I teach 11th grade English okay
so $24,000 a year paid off average for
two years a total of 48 yet making 30 to
42 you must have sold something we sold
a lot of stuff Dave what was the big
things you sold my motorcycle
what was it how much was it when we
bought it it was eight thousand would
you sell it for a little over four okay
about 45 okay and what else we sold a
lot on eBay I became like eBay obsessed
I would see something on sale and I'm
like oh I can sell that for more so we
would buy things to resell and just
things lying around the house I'll show
you made some money doing yes plus
cleaned out some miscellaneous move so
how much of the forty eight thousand do
you think you did offer though what the
ebay moves I would say good three
thousand dollars okay all right that was
a motorcycle seven then all right so
that gets us down to like forty-one
thousand that you did and then you've
been on beans and rice for two years
well he's Puerto Rican so beans and rice
is a staple anyway so we we ate like all
you
that's funny we always and Brahmin going
to college it's all we had time for yeah
okay so you're in school yeah time
basically we're in school we don't even
see each other we just did homework
worked and got out and got out of that
I'm sorry I took a pizza-delivery John
lucky mention yeah and that made a lot
of extra income too
during those two years okay so have you
both graduated now yes and your degrees
are in what I have I got my bachelor's
in English and then master's and a
secondary education cool adding you know
teaching yes okay are you and you said
you're doing that already yes I just
started in January okay so that's gonna
raise your income there okay and berto
what do you do right now I do security I
got my bachelor's in criminal justice
and I'm I'm gonna put myself through
school on paid for by the military
police academy okay very cool very cool
good for you
excellent well this is incredible you
guys what kind of debt was the 48
thousand I would say a little bit of
everything we had student loans yeah we
took out I had first few years I used my
GI Bill and then we started working for
the school so we got a big discount my
Master's was totally paid for by our
schools so that was because you were
working there cuz they work there
full-time
that's smart yes we both worked for the
school so I finished my bachelor's
degree and she finished her master's
fully funded when when you were working
for the school what was your job I
worked actually admissions office so I
answered phone calls and helping people
get admitted to the college okay and now
was the bad guy I was the parking
enforcement yeah there seems to be a
theme here with you very good cool you
guys very fun so how's it feel now after
all the sacrifice it's still like a
shock because we never saw each other
and it's just we're debt-free now like
and it's I don't it's amazing and we
finished school and we're debt-free so
your income is probably gonna double in
the next two years
my
we first start I already feel like we're
millionaires because that went from
working at Walmart to being a teacher
big difference way to go you guys
congratulations the future is bright
thank you I love it so when someone
thinks you're weird and that you've lost
your mind and you're out of debt and
then they kind of go wait you paid off
48 pounds how did you do that what do
you tell them just working hard and
sacrificing we never went out to eat
people didn't understand they're like
why don't you come out with us suddenly
because we can't spend money on that and
I even went overboard and if I would
never spend money on food if I forgot it
I would just wait until I got home but
just making those little sacrifices that
kind of all added up together and not
going out not spending money budgeting
every month I would say yes helped us a
lot
very cool very cool so you thought you
so you think just scrimping and saving
just not spending money and thinking
about purchases for a long time a big
purchase to me is like $50 so we would
just think about everything do we really
need this now can we wait until it goes
on sale so things like that very cool
well congratulations you too I'm very
proud of you congratulate that this is
just you your future is amazing you guys
if you can pull off what you pulled off
you can do anything I mean you heard me
talking about 69 year old guy worth five
million dollars that's you amazing
that's where you're gonna be I mean and
you're gonna be there before you're 69
that's where you're going
way to go you two very very fun all
right Berto and Ashley Orlando Kissimmee
Florida I love it
$48,000 paid off in two years making 30
now making 42 a year count it down let's
hear a debt free scream
I love it I love it I love it very well
done excellent job you guys
excellent job
you